this is definitely the biggest challenge that
ludwig has faced in in either of his pog champs
in either of the podcamps that he's played in
um and i think we're to see how good his nerves
are because he's got to know himself that he is
the under dog starters has been playing a lot
more than he has it's going to be very exciting
yep it'll be interesting right because we see
sardosh has that hafu kind of vibe grind right
he came in he's just been you know grinding for
the last month we know he's also been working with
kevin bourdee blitzstream also gets a huge shout
out for for working with sardoche but but then
you have that experience factor because because
ludwig's been here since pog one and we've
been seeing him stream chess for what the last
eight months now right and we know
that's gotta account for something
in regards to his experience so we'll i wonder
how that'll play out here between the two of them
now we'll start i should go for the uh the
the double lift on the h file with rook
h4 and rook ddh1 i guess it's not actually
lifts that's just a double doubling up but
will they play rook h4 and rook d to h1 is uh
is actually quite a serious question here right
well the only thing even stronger potentially
is something with g4 i mean if he finds
and recognizes the idea to undermine the knight
and open this diagonal that would be that would be
and i don't put it past him he did play the grab
for a while and then he realized how bad that was
shout out to kevin bourdie good coaching
left that behind but he does know of g4 right
that is true okay h6 logical stuff look
at sarkozy 95 95 or g4 right away too
what a game by both these guys right now i mean
this is a this is a this is pogchamps 3 presented
by grip 6 everybody but this is some quality
chess here by by these two guys i think that
ludwig is in really bad shape um but again we'll
see we'll see what he does because he is deep and
deep and he is deep in thought right now and the
very close game on the clock these two guys are
feeling the gravity the weight of the
situation sardoche with a few good options
yeah many good options g4 f4 and knight
df3 are probably the three best moves
um in this position now if he sees the idea of
pushing the pawns forward to open it up then i
understand he goes rook h3 which i don't like yeah
i don't like rookie h3 at all here um it to me it
feels like sardosh is not actually seeing the idea
now mind you f4 it's it's hard to play because you
hang g3 multiple ways um but i think what he needs
to realize is that time matters here time really
does matter you have to you have to be fast let's
see what led's about to do i think i want to go f6
but how does he follow
oh he does go to absolutely i
think sardoche will see it now
pretty confident sorry for seeing 97. he
falls there and ludwig saw it too right
after he played it he highlighted it and the
thing is i did see it too right yeah okay
tough spot to be in for ludwig here but it's not
over actually in a way it's good that he gives
up the material because now he's more chances to
kind of defend the position it's not so easy for
white to just attack anymore i was just going
to say that it's like almost the accidental
blunder because that night and and the potential
sardocy already had with opening up the position
is actually kind of going away now
so he's going to win the rook right
but this is this is not over i'm more worried
about ludwig being down a minute on the clock
than i am on the position right now right agreed
yeah the position is relatively okay here for um
for ludwig right but again ludwig's plays
knight before yeah a3982 when black is winning
a392 and then you stack a knight and you get
the fork oh my god what a sick move i gotta
show if a3 knight a2 flip the script and drop
a fork like it's hot keep it pg no thank you
right if you go to d1 it's the same thing
exact same thing that is a nasty tactic
it's just shots wow well you saw it instantly
dude i wouldn't see that if i had 10 minutes
there's a kingdom oh he played
f3 blood has it if he sees it
although that's obviously that was super hard
but still oh man i don't know but i don't
think it was hard danny because this pawn was
hanging for free it was a check it was for free
so i actually don't think it was super hard
if you'd use time that's why it started if
sardosh goes a3 i understand it being hard
to find it but the fact that it's a free pawn
and it's worth a check um i think he
should have he actually should have
found it but again both players are
getting low on time so it's not easy
it looks like he's backing up not that bad though
chief
yeah of course he sees it not surprising
because you don't just start really sweating
queen e3 is a great move too
what a great game by these two guys right here
this is awesome to see the championship racket
come down to this kind of chess and there's
only one good move for white here which is
rook to h1 otherwise black is knight f6 or
bishop to e2 collecting one of the rooks here
well knight f6 93 but does ludwig
see it this is it this could be the
the win of game one if he sees knight f6 it's only
one pawn so it's still quite a ways to go but yeah
oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no he's gonna
see it yeah take your time don't move your king
surprise like he's working through candidates
now he sees it yeah you're gonna see it yeah he's
gonna play it for sure yeah wow awesome [ __ ] i
like that he worked through what he did there
everyone to learn from it is he considered a
movie didn't play it and he kept working through
the position and he eventually found knight f6
right and now you can see also when you look
at sardoche how on edge he is um and again
this is the thing i would say to sardosh i feel
like when he doesn't have a clear-cut idea he
kind of he can get too nervous and bad things can
happen and um i mean he was dominating this game
but ludwig again stayed in the game he's hung
around and sure he missed this knight knight
eight takes a2 idea but overall finding
really good moves yep wow a5 okay uh-oh
okay now that was a pretty severe mistake
yeah by ludwig because now the keys
he could he could have left the pawn
uh-oh we'll start don't see rook takes e6 yeah
this late game whoa doesn't okay now ludwig's
in the driver's seat yep carter's has to take
with the d-pawn he takes with the f pawn it's
over but he takes with a pawn but now can love
would find a move like bishop b5 ooh king b6
i think this is still probably a draw
with correct play yeah but wow what a game
and see the problem with this end game is that
it's um is that it's a light square bishop that's
the problem the bishop can't touch any of any of
white's pawns yeah bishop is just it's opposite
colors now king d6 and i think white is probably
winning now can starters keep it together and go
king d6 is a big question if he goes king d6
i think he's winning here white could be up a
night and still lose the game to the corner pull
up right oh there's a f5 now though will starters
go f5 oh man f5 is winning you use the two the
two the two pawns go up the board will he find
it or not no he plays e6 first that's not a bad
move either yeah cause ludwig probably won't take
wow this is crazy i think this is still winning
for white after bishop takes pawn but very hard
to play now after king takes pawn i think it
should be winning for sardosh look at his focus
blood hasn't talked in like three
minutes somebody somebody calls some help
you know something's the best move um
what a move by sartosh 93 wow that's
impressive and now knight f5 and you
go the other way after the uh pawn and h4 and
i think there's almost no chance that sardosh
misses it because the only piece you can move here
is the knife yeah you're right yeah there's just
no way mrs knight of five amazing stuff from
what technique there seriously you're right
yep wow amazing stuff that's probably better
end game technique than i've displayed in
more than a decade hikaru let's be honest
yeah i mean star does really actually i've said
that his nerves have been his biggest biggest
issue he's really kept it together well in this
game from the winning position which i'm sure he
knew he had to then when he was down a pawn in the
middle game to keep going uh very very impressive
give up your c pawn and hope for stalemate
nope but sardoche getting surgical up in
those dark squares thanks marcellus wallace
fires in a blowtorch on g7 and we got problems
this this is going to be an amazing
thing that was an amazing game
what a game
what a game right and so we have the
allopin um or we have the the knight
f6 variation played here against
the alpine cylinder c3 sicilian
um gonna be very interesting to see what happens
i think your ludwig i don't know if ludwig has
looked at this but i would hope that he's um
that he's looked at this a little bit at least
but i still think a6 is completely
reasonable too but oh no not queen a4 no
super risky i think there are many options
that are good for for black here i mean i think
bishop d7 is great wow he just played it
without even a second thought what a move
wow and cers goes knight c7 i mean i don't
even know what to say he's just playing this
like gm so far he really is knight t7 was an
all-star move just because now you can put
the bishop on d5 and get a wooden shield you
also open up the diagonal as well towards h1
yeah one risk of nice c7 though is if he
if he doesn't follow through with it and
let's say he he makes the mistake of taking
with the pawn ludwig is cancelled ooh and
see but that's definitely not a good idea
that is definitely not a grand master move
look how far we've come we're actually criticizing
them on the level of like strong i mean in a
good way they're they're playing good shots
that is definitely not a grand master move
you highlighted it well though seriously if
you if he develops the knight and puts the
two brooks in the center he's in a good shape
right now the thing is however i think for sardo
she should close the center with pawn to d5
and then try to develop the bushman castle um
i think it's really important that he tries to
do that yeah and a good reminder for you know
we know a big chess audience learning the game
is you almost never want to take a piece that
helps your opponent develop a piece almost
never and bishop takes d2 did just that so
hey queen c3 is also not bad but ludwig can't okay
you see she three okay but you got it you gotta
get going over here on the queen side well rook c1
and queen c6 is a huge threat here so um it's also
on it's also on sardocher he has to stop that
he's playing rook c if he does not play rook c8
white's going to get rook c1 and he does wow okay
so now we'll playing knight b3 and get the bastion
huge moment yeah rook c1 is not as good as
it looks because sardos can move the knight
and take care of everything but knight
b3 a8 only move by the way danny eight
is the only square because the e8 you lose
ah so he'll be forced to find the corner
jump and then come to c4 so that's also
why rook c1 is is not not the best move
because knight f3 not a bad movie either but not
best because now i think i think there's a good
chance stardust will see the idea of getting
his knight to see four with knight ap succeed
right the lord plays rook joint now the question
is will ludwig realize he's got to take with
a knight here because again a draw is not good
enough in this position right he has to so i think
we'll realize that yeah he's got to take
with the knight because it's an end game
and a draw is not good enough here so he's got to
take with a knight and keep the rook on the board
good move by ludwig two thumbs up again
it's now become easier moves for low which
is also critical because he was running out
of time c6 yeah i mean this is getting whoa
this is starting to turn around this is
starting to turn around here he goes c6
this is starting to turn big big moment
here for ludwig that's that's the mogu
i think he's going to make it magnus proud someone
clipped that i think he's going to see rook h7
yeah i think he's gonna find
rook h7 here wow dude yep
better thinking faster playing smarter
smoke a cigarette frenchie you seem stressed out
it's just a chess game about [ __ ] relax
thousands happened in the time we've been playing
wow sardoce is i mean i think ludwig could win
this game he totally can win this game and the
other reason that i think he can win is because
again the only i only routing of the knight
that that works here is c7 8 b64 it's again a
very unusual pathing of the night and i just
i don't whoa maybe he sees it though he
found the first move he found knight c7
okay this is i mean again it yeah does he see
this or was it was this sort of just the lucky
lucky square that he picked i think it
might just be a lucky square that he picked
yeah i think you're yeah it's just so ran it's
just so weird moving you're moving your knight
to the corner it's just it's a weird concept that
i mean the pathing is just so strange yep and and
the fact that it's so tricky is is going to make
it easier for you you know you're totally right
but ludwig's going the wrong way with the king he
needs to go to the kings now he's figured it out
yeah now he's got it yep and here we go king comes
into f6 and he's gonna get this thing i think
ludwig's gonna win yeah because now he's gonna
see knight f8 next move what a brilliant game
what a brilliant recovery by ludwig it actually
you know it feels like in the end games ludwig has
been a little bit better than than sardosh it's
just the critical moments um in that first game
just like one or two little minor mistakes shifted
it but like in this game he's just outplayed
sardosh in this whole end game and now knight f8
oh wow what am i looking at the game right now
from ludwig and he's going to win he's going to
win wow wake up boys and girls we're headed down
to a tiebreaker yeah it's a tiebreaker yep wow man
all in sick drink your favorite your vermont day
wait can i say it like that don't miss
again that's right wow and first design
i always lose the first i always lose the first
did you just do a trump impersonation oh my god
we don't want to talk about that you said i
always lose them wow that was weird oh my gosh
by the way i love this opening i think this is
actually in a blitz game very beneficial for white
i think it was much more advantageous um because
i think i think it's unless you know exactly
how to develop with black um i i think that uh in
general it's it's really um it's it's really hard
to play you'll have to use a lot of time figuring
out how to develop your piece now let's remember
this is no longer a draw odds for for black
which between these two guys might have
mattered because sardosh might be able so
this is good good for ludwig shout out to
ezra's monkey you also love your username yeah
exactly so let's see what happens here okay
queen d2 threatens bishop h6 if black gets
castle so this is advantage ludwig in the opening
gardosh feeling the pressure yeah definitely i
think here for sardoche um he takes on e5 very
scary move now knight takes pawn is playable pawn
takes pawn i think there might be an f6 trick here
oh yeah that would but i think it's very scary
to play i think it's very scary to go f6 here
light takes i think f6 is probably
good for black but very scary to play
see what happens
oh he finds f6 okay amazing
he takes right away yeah bishop h6 is probably
the best move here but tough move to play
he's up one minute on the clock it's
still very much a game knight c3 is
a good no don't take it ludwig
don't panic oh no he's panicking
he's had such good
whoa nerves that work or not quick yes because
he has bishop e6 wow even if one of them
oh wow almost a huge blunder by sargosh this
might have been yeah i mean what happened
knight d5 though not knight d5 okay okay it's
not over this is crazy it's
not so great you're already
this is insane like ludwig totally panicked and
lost his mind there 7 by sardosh what a move
great move by sardosh
it's like when he doesn't have time to think
he's actually playing better yeah he's playing
like much better than when he had time to think
yep pretty amazing this very there's almost
nothing i can say negative about this game sort
of just played an amazing game yeah seriously the
fact that he found f6 2 was huge i mean he blood
was all in when he knew he was better and up on
time but it's one of those tricky moments he kind
of got a little unlucky with knight takes e5 but
still it's it's really hard to know that you don't
have to start sacrificing you know right yeah
yeah and now the moves play themselves
bishop c5 check and rook h1 is beat yeah
ouch oh the fork yeah i mean basically the
reason that i would say i mean ludwig lost
this game is because he panicked he just he
panicked in the middle there for a couple of
for a couple of moves that
was really the difference um
in general yeah there's sardosh i've seen him mate
with king and rook he just he knows how to mate
there's just no way i mean that temple with the
rook wasn't even necessary he delivers it wow
yeah i know i mean i saw that coming yeah yeah
yeah yeah we saw it in his match against nico
that's one thing that i noticed even in pog 2 the
people who um the people who had that technique
where they could ignore half the board whether
like a king of rook or a king and a queen um those
those were the guys who were very very dangerous
and you could tell very early on that sargon
you can see how much this means to him just crazy
blood here's the thing dude like a badass
mogul moves everywhere i know this didn't
end how you wanted but man i mean i feel money
i actually like when i lost to charlie no cap
and consolation i was like crushed i was like
sad i wanted to win but i i realized because
i started coaching with hess way before this
tournament was announced before i knew about it
uh all i've wanted to do is just get better at
chess and i think much like logic felt after
losing it i just feel good like i'm i'm cracked
now bro like i i took a game off sardosh dude
you saw everything i was planning to do you always
come to play it uh you missed some blunder as i
did obviously but well yeah i was i was i was in
more difficulty than in my uh 1400 games actually
i was impressed at your speed because usually
i'm pretty up on time control in my games
and i definitely had to tank for like half my
moves because uh because you had like bro you
you playing like a true frenchie dude i can't get
it i i knew you would actually try to flag me so i
will never let the clock uh yeah get for for your
favor uh i would play a move even though it wasn't
the best but uh it was important for me to to put
a pressure on you so you could actually blender so
yeah yeah it definitely worked because i think
game one i i definitely had a lead i knew that
after i took the rook with the night fork and
then i was lower on the clock in my end game
you know i'm sad to say i lost to vorsky's endgame
manual on the move and uh yeah that hurts you're
really good at the game actually i i didn't train
that enough i didn't win enough into terry you
can't say i'm good when you beat me in it that's
not how it works but guys i mean you guys you guys
seriously played fantastic chess and hikaru and i
were i mean i i said before we went to right here
no but i mean you know i think to be to
be clear i mean i think actually yeah like
ludwig i mean sardosh is not wrong i thought in
the end games you played really really well like
that second game especially when you were down the
pawn and at the start with the rooks in the night
you played that extremely well just the whole
way moving the rook and taking the pawn on one
side and bringing the rook back to the other side
to grab the other pawn and bringing the king in
i mean i i couldn't have done it better myself
so i i think you're selling yourself a little
bit short because that end game was was amazing we
said on camera mud right here we said he said if
blood finds rook a7 called magnus because we
got some mogul moves going and you played it
and rookie this was literally brand master
level end game technique i believe you not
you